Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere
kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 128.
Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Und heute schieße ich euch alle ein wenig zum Mond,
denn das soll das Thema heute sein.
Und dafür bin ich nach Münster gefahren, an die Universität Münster und sitze
jetzt hier im Institut für Planetologie. und begrüße meinen Gesprächspartner,
Harald Hirsinger. Hallo.
Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Ja, du bist ja Professor an der Universität
für geologische Planetologie.
Genau, richtig, ja.
Das spricht sich gut aus.
Heißt also alles, was mit der Substanz von Planeten zu tun hat.
Genau, wir beschäftigen uns mit der Entwicklung von Planeten,
die geologische Entwicklung,
Fragestellungen wie welcher Vulkanismus ist wann, wo, wie aufgetreten,
wie haben sich Krater auf dem Planeten gebildet, solche Dinge,
Wasser auf dem Mars heißt das Thema.
Also wir sind quer durchs ganze Sonnensystem unterwegs.
Seit wann gibt es diese Abteilung hier schon?
Die ist tatsächlich gegründet worden mit meiner Ankunft hier in Münster im Jahr 2006.
Mein Vorgänger hat etwas anders gemacht, das entwickelt sich dann eben so ganz
organisch und seit 2006.
Aber Geologie hat hier schon immer eine Rolle gespielt. Ja klar.
Wir gehören auch zum Fachbereich Geowissenschaften hier in Münster und sind da gut verortet.
Ja, du reißt dich hier übrigens auch schön ein in die Liste der Gesprächspartner,
nämlich in die Liste von Richard Meusel, Michael Kahn und Rainer Kresken.
Du ahnst schon, was kommt, oder?
Das sind andere Leute, nach denen ein Asteroid benannt wurde.
26811 habe ich hier notiert.
Genau, ja.
Wie erreicht einen so eine Botschaft?
Die ist tatsächlich beim DAWN-Team-Meeting verkündet worden.
DAWN war eine NASA-Mission zu den Asteroiden Ceres und Vesta,
an der ich beteiligt war.
Und ja, im Zuge von dieser Mission hat dann tatsächlich jeder Wissenschaftler
einen Asteroiden nach ihm benannt bekommen.
Also ich bin da nichts Besonderes, ich bin einer unter vielen.
Es ist auch ein ganz kleiner Asteroid, der irgendwo im Hauptgürtel rumschwebt.
Und uns Gott sei Dank nicht auf den Kopf fällt, soweit wir das wissen.
Aber ja, man hat den großen Vorteil, Asteroiden darf man benennen,
wenn man ihn entdeckt hat und den Orbit bestimmt hat.
Und ja, so bin ich zu dem Asteroiden gekommen.
Nicht, dass ihn er jetzt selbst entdeckt hat, sondern jemand anderes hat das
entdeckt, aber er hat ihm dann die Namensgebung im Zug gefällt,
dass die ganzen Dornwissenschaftler einen Asteroiden bekommen.
Das ist ja nett.
Ja, sehr nett.
War das überraschend?
War völlig überraschend. Ich habe damit überhaupt nicht gerechnet.
Das Gute ist das, ein Asteroiden darf nach jemandem benannt werden, der noch lebt.
Wenn man einen Mondgrad oder einen anderen Grad nach sich benannt haben will,
dann muss man mindestens drei Jahre tot sein.
Also da kann ich gerne noch drauf warten und kann erst mal drauf verzichten.
Okay, ja, okay, gut. Dann ist das eine gute Nachricht. Also wenn ein Asteroiden
nach einem benannt wird, dann lebt man zumindest noch.
Genau. Man kann ihn auch genießen.
Erzähl doch mal kurz, wie du überhaupt zur Wissenschaft gekommen bist und warum
du dich mit diesem Thema angelegt hast.
Also ich habe ganz normal Wald- und Wiesengeologie in München studiert und bin
dann erst mit der Promotion eigentlich in die Planetologie gekommen.
Also ich bin jetzt nicht so das klassische fünfjährige Kind, das schon gewusst hat,
Ich brauche unbedingt der Teleskop und ich will unbedingt den Mond erforschen.
Da bin ich spät berufen, wirklich erst nach dem Diplom.
Und ja, ich bin in Oberpfaffenhofen dann beim Herrn Neukum aufgeschlagen.
Neukum hat damals diese Arbeitsgruppe am DLR geleitet.
Gerhard Neukum.
Gerhard Neukum, genau. Und wir sind da im sehr schnellen Übereinkommen,
dass ich den Vulkanismus im Sonnensystem erstmal untersuchen soll,
das ist natürlich ein Riesenthema und man hat sich dann letztendlich auf Vulkanismus auf dem Mond reduziert,
was dann auch machbar war.
Und ja, da habe ich eben meine Promotionszeit damit verbracht,
diese schwarzen Flecken auf dem Mond zu datieren mit Graterhäufigkeiten.
Im Prinzip ist je mehr Grater, desto älter ist die Oberfläche.
Und so kann man das dann über so Kalibrationen mit den Gesteinsproben der Apollo-Missionen
dann auch absolut datieren, dass ich ihm weiß, so ein paar Saltes vor 3,5 oder
3,6 oder 3,8 Milliarden Jahren ausgeflossen.
Das war aber jetzt nicht so eine Standardmethode. die allgemein bekannt war,
sondern das ist etwas, was am DLR überhaupt erst vorangetrieben wurde,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also Herr Neukölln war natürlich da einer derjenigen, der diese Methode verfeinert
hat, weiterentwickelt hat.
Die Anfänge gehen so bis in die 60er Jahre zurück.
Aber ja, Herr Neukölln war da sehr, sehr maßgeblich in der Entwicklung von dieser
Methode beteiligt. Und ich habe natürlich als kleiner Doktorand davon profitiert,
von seinem Erfahrungsschatz.
Und ich bin dann auch unterstützt worden von Professor Jaumann.
Der mich dann eben auch auf der vulkanischen Seite sehr unterstützt hat.
Also das war sehr gute Zusammenarbeit dort.
Erst in Oberpfaffenhofen und dann nach der Wiedervereinigung sind wir alle umzogen
nach Berlin, nach Adlershof.
Sind dann auch ein Eigensinstitut worden. Also ich habe den Aufbau von diesem
Institut damals tatsächlich miterleben dürfen.
Es waren sehr, sehr spannende Zeiten und ich habe die Zeit da eigentlich sehr genossen.
Aber 1997 bin ich dann letztendlich nach Amerika gegangen, war dann zehn Jahre
in Amerika unterwegs, erst an der Brown University und dann in Connecticut an
der Universität unterwegs.
Ich war dann Professor da drüben und dann hat es ihm 2006 die Chance gegeben,
hier nach Münster zu kommen.
Ich habe mich beworben, bin ausgewählt worden und seit 2006 arbeite ich jetzt
hier am Institut für Planetologie und habe so eine kleine Arbeitsgruppe mit 25, 30 Leuten momentan,
vom Bachelorstudenten über Master,
Doktorand, Postdoc, Techniker.
Also alles, was man halt so braucht für so ein kleines Institut. Macht riesig Spaß hier.
Muss ich sagen. Und indirekt überall die Finger drin in zahlreichen Missionen,
die so auf der Welt ablaufen.
Wir sind ganz gut unterwegs, ja. Also ein ganz spannendes Thema ist ja die Beppi-Colombo-Mission,
die jetzt im Herbst ja nach Merkur, vielen, vielen Jahren Flugzeug am Merkur ankommen wird.
Dort haben wir ein Instrument tatsächlich an Bord, das ich als Hauptverantwortlicher
mit jemandem, Solmar Sadili aus dem DLEA in Berlin betreuen darf.
Und ja, wir sind natürlich jetzt sehr gespannt, endlich am Merkur anzukommen.
Wir sind im Oktober 2018 gestartet.
Und ich bin jetzt seit 2007 arbeite ich an dieser Mission.
Und jetzt ist es dann endlich soweit, dass wir unsere Daten kriegen.
Und das ist natürlich...
Hat Raumzeit auch schon darüber berichtet. Damals habe ich mich mit Elsa Mortagnon unterhalten.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wie er da die Missionsplanung gemacht hat, über die Planung.
Und ja, auch bin ich auch sehr gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Und wahrscheinlich auch ein alter Kollege von dir, Tilman Spohn.
Ja, klar.
Mit dem habe ich mich über den Merkur unterhalten, was man damals halt 2012
so wusste über den Merkur.
Und ich schätze mal, da wissen wir demnächst gleich noch ein bisschen mehr.
Was kann dieses Instrument?
Das ist ein thermales Infrarotspektrometer, das dazu gebaut worden ist,
die Mineralogie und die Zusammensetzung der Oberfläche zu bestimmen.
Und es gibt da natürlich noch andere Instrumente, wie ein richtig tolles Kamerasystem,
das aus Italien kommt und ein tolles Laseraltimeter, das auch aus dem DLR in Berlin kommt.
Und noch ein Neutronenspektrometer aus Großbritannien.
Das sind so einige der wesentlichen Instrumente, um die Geochemie,
die Mineralogie, die Topografie, den Innenaufbau zum Studieren.
Zu dem Instrumentensuite gehört dann auch noch das Magnetometer aus Braunschweig.
Also wir sind eine richtig gute, enge Gruppe,
Wo sich das eine Instrument sehr, sehr gut ergänzt mit den anderen Instrumenten
und die Hoffnung ist eben,
dass man über diese enge Zusammenarbeit sehr viel mehr über Merkur lernen kann,
als wenn man sich in seinen eigenen kleinen Elfenbeinturm zurückzieht und eben
nur seine Daten von seinem kleinen Instrument betrachtet.
Na, das will ich ja wohl meinen, dass man da dann doch mehr rausfindet.
Wann ist jetzt, das ist jetzt Ende dieses Jahres, wo soll das stattfinden?
Das heißt, das wird dann sozusagen auch dich 20 Jahre begleitet haben.
Ja, genau. Wir kommen am Merkur im Herbst an und die wirkliche Wissenschaft,
den wissenschaftlichen Orbitz erreichen wir dann im Frühjahr und ab dann geht es richtig los.
Also genau genommen ist man ja schon seit fünf Jahren am Merkur,
aber man muss halt nochmal komplizierte Schleifchen machen, um dann letzten
Endes so dort anzukommen, dass man dann halt auch da in ein Orbit treten kann.
Ja spannend, also ich finde das immer total irre.
Glück, sage ich mal, dass wir den Merkur-E-Mert schon in den Vorbeiflügen zumindest
bei einigen beobachten haben können. Wir haben also schon die ersten Merkur-Daten.
Das heißt, die Instrumente funktionieren auch.
Unser Instrument funktioniert, genau. Das ist die gute Nachricht.
So ist es. Ja, man ist ja schon nervös, wenn man jahrelang an sowas gearbeitet hat.
Und dann ist das für viele Jahre unterwegs.
Und die Kamera und solche Instrumente konnten eben noch nicht getestet werden.
Wir haben viel von diesen Vorbeiflügen schon gelernt. wie wir unser Instrument
letztendlich handhaben müssen,
wo es Fallstricke gibt, was wir verbessern haben müssen und das ist also eine
Lektion, die sehr, sehr wichtig war, dass man solche Instrumente bereits auf
der sogenannten Cruise-Phase, also wenn man anreist,
dass man die da bereits testen kann.
Die Tätigkeit, also als du dann beim Institut für Planetenforschung angefangen
hast, das heißt der Mond war jetzt durch den Gerhard Neukum da ohnehin schon ein besonderes Thema.
Genau, ja.
Und diese Methode der Kraterzählung, also was war da jetzt so neu dran und was
hat man dadurch herausfinden können, was vorher vielleicht nicht so klar war?
Also die Methode ist eben, wie gesagt, über die Jahre verfeinert worden.
Wir verstehen die Methode jetzt viel, viel besser als noch vor 10,
20 Jahren, weil ich auch hier in meiner Arbeitsgruppe mittlerweile sehr,
sehr viel Zeit eben drauf verwende, diese Methode zum Verfeinern neu zu kalibrieren.
Ich habe da viele Doktorarbeiten auch auf dieses Thema angesetzt,
was einfach fundamental wichtig ist, weil diese Methode,
erlaubt mir eigentlich mit ganz simplen Annahmen sehr, sehr wichtige Ergebnisse zu produzieren.
Das klingt ja jetzt mal erst sehr simpel, wenn ich die Anzahl der Krater zähle,
desto länger, oder je häufiger diese Krater im Auftreten, desto länger war die
Oberfläche dem Asteroidenbombardement ausgesetzt und viele Krater bedeuten dann
eben alte Oberfläche und wenig Krater bedeuten der junge Oberfläche.
Wenn man halt davon ausgeht, dass der Körper erstmal so einen vulkanischen Ursprung
hat, das war alles flüssig, dann ist es gehärtet und dann schlägt die Uhr.
Aber wie kann man jetzt aus den Kratern dann eine konkrete Zahl für das Alter bestimmen? Genau.
Wenn man die Grater auch um die Landestellen, die Apollo-Landestellen und die
Luna-Landestellen zählt, dann habe ich von diesem Gebiet ja auch Gesteinsproben,
die hier auf der Erde radiometrisch datieren kann,
über bestimmte Isotopenverhältnisse.
Und dann kann ich eben sagen, okay, eine bestimmte Anzahl an Gratern entspricht
einem bestimmten Alter.
Ah, okay, das ist sozusagen die Vergleichsgröße.
Genau, und genau da wird es eben super wichtig, weil...
Diese Methode ermöglicht mir dann nicht nur die Datierung von den Gebieten,
die bereits besucht waren,
sondern ich kann sie eben dann global auf dem ganzen Mond anwenden und letztendlich
die Alter der Oberfläche auch von Gebieten bestimmen auf dem Mond,
wo noch nie ein Astronaut war.
Weil man sozusagen davon ausgeht, dass dieselbe Zufallsverteilung da ist.
Genau, so schaut es aus. Ich habe so, was wir die lunare Chronologiefunktion
nennen, Das ist so die Referenzkurve, die eben die Anzahl der Krater mit den
radiometrischen Altern verheiratet.
Und mit der Information kann ich die gesamte Oberfläche des Mondes datieren.
Und wo es dann wirklich spannend wird, ist, ich kann diese Methode unter gewissen
Annahmen eben auch auf die anderen Körper im Sonnensystem anwenden,
speziell die inneren Planeten.
Da muss ich eben dann andere Parameter berücksichtigen. die Anziehungskraft
von dem Körper, die Größe vom Körper, die Einschlagsgeschwindigkeit,
weil die natürlich einen Effekt hat auf die Größe des Gratens, der sich bildet.
Aber mit diesen Annahmen kann ich eben die Methode dann dazu verwenden,
Gebiete auf dem Mars zum datieren, Gebiete auf dem Merkur zum datieren.
Und selbst auf der Venus, wo man nur 1000 Einschlagsgrade hat,
wenn man da das Mondmodell anwendet, dann weiß man eben, dass sich,
Oberfläche der Venus vor 300 bis 800 Millionen Jahren komplett erneuert hat.
Das ist fantastisch. Das waren Erkenntnisse, die man gar nicht so unbedingt hat erwarten können.
Wie passiert es, dass sich ein Planet innerhalb von relativ kurzer Zeit komplett erneuert?
Das ist super. Oder wenn ich auf den Mars schaue und Olympus den großen Vulkan anschaue.
Wie lange dauert Bis sich so ein großen Vulkan, der 22 Kilometer hoch ist,
gebildet hat. Solche Dinge kann man untersuchen.
Man kann untersuchen, wie hat sich die Zusammensetzung der Larven geändert.
Wenn sich die über mehrere Milliarden Jahre an der Oberfläche ablagern,
dann kann es durchaus sein, dass das nicht immer die gleiche Zusammensetzung
ist, sondern sich systematische Änderungen ergeben.
Also das sind so ein paar Dinge, die mich umtreiben und die auch schon in meiner
Doktorarbeit so ein bisschen anklungen sind.
Ich habe, wie gesagt, diese dunklen Flecken auf dem Mond mal systematisch untersucht
und habe da auch nochmal so im Detail ein paar ganz neue Ansätze entwickelt.
Und so sehen wir halt, dass der Mond über mindestens drei Milliarden Jahre vulkanisch
aktiv war. Und das ist einfach wie der Blick ins Geschichtsbuch.
Auf der Erde ist das nicht möglich.
Erde ist eben sehr dynamisch, Plattentektonik, Atmosphäre, Leben,
verwischt, alles was in der Frühphase vom Sonnensystem passiert ist,
die Gesteine sind zum Großteil vernichtet, auf dem Mond sind sie mehr halten geblieben.
Aber ist es nicht so, dass die Zahl der Krater auf der erdnahen Seite anders
ist als auf der erdfernen Seite oder ist das alles gleichmäßig verteilt?
Wir gehen also im Prinzip schon davon aus, dass es plus minus gleich verteilt
ist, aber es gibt auch Studien, das ist schon richtig, wo…,
modelliert haben, dass die Einschlagshäufigkeit in manchen Gebieten etwas höher
ist als in anderen Gebieten.
Also das gibt es tatsächlich, diese Modelle, aber in meinen Zählungen ist mir
das jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so wirklich aufgefallen.
Bei Rot weiß man, kennt man die Zahl jetzt. Also die ist ja jetzt kein Mysterium.
Jeder Krater ist gezählt.
Nee, bei Weib nicht. Nee, das schaffen wir gar nicht.
Wieso?
Auch da ist der Mond absolut einmalig. Also wir sehen kleine Krater auf Glaskügelchen,
vulkanischen Glaskügelchen, die von den Apollo-Astronauten mitgebracht worden sind.
Und diese Krater sind ein Millimeter groß.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir… Millimeter.
Das zählt als Krater?
Das ist wirklich eine schöne Vertiefung in so einem Glaskügelchen.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir eben auch das größte Einschlagsbecken im Sonnensystem,
das Haus Polekenbecken, auf der südlichen Mondrückseite mit 2400 Kilometer im Durchmesser.
Das heißt also, ich kann den Graterbildungsprozess vom Millimeterbereich bis
zu 2500 Kilometer Größe, kann ich mehr oder weniger kontinuierlich studieren,
weil ich Grater aller Größen letztendlich auf dem Mond finde.
Und das ist natürlich auf dem Mars zum Beispiel nicht möglich,
weil Mars hat eine Atmosphäre, da würden sich diese kleinen Projektile in der
Atmosphäre verglühen und würden nie so ganz kleine Krater bilden.
Das heißt, man kann noch weitere Informationen über den Mond gewinnen,
indem man ihn noch genauer beobachtet, um noch mehr und kleinere Krater zu erkennen?
Ja, also wir können eben mit kleinen Kratern dann auch kleinere Gebiete datieren,
weil die Statistik dann wieder gut wird, weil man eben kleine Krater hat und davon hat man viele.
Dadurch wird die Statistik besser. Aber man muss auch sagen,
auch die Methode hat natürlich ihre Grenzen, weil ich, wenn ich mir die ganz
kleinen Grater anschaue,
und klein heißt jetzt so unter 300 Meter, dann kommen andere Effekte zum Tragen,
nämlich sogenannte Target Properties, also wie sind die physikalischen Eigenschaften
der Oberfläche, wie zäh ist das Material,
wie hart ist das Material und dementsprechend bilden sich dann eben andere Kratergrößen
als relativ gesehen zu den großen Kratern.
Also da muss man aufpassen, das ist eben das, was ich vorher gemeint habe,
diese Methode wird permanent immer verfeinert und da stecken wir sehr viel Hirnschmalz
rein, um eben nicht, sage ich mal,
uns zu falschen Interpretationen hinreißen zu lassen.
Ja, aber okay, jetzt beim Mond hat man den Vergleich, weil man schon da war
und man kann eben die Materialien nehmen und radiometrisch da bearbeiten.
Das haben wir sonst, weiß nicht, beim Mars?
Nee, haben wir tatsächlich nur für den Mond.
Nur für den Mond.
Nur für den Mond, weil ich brauche die genaue Beziehung, Und wo sind diese Proben
genommen worden, damit ich meine Krater um diese Stelle drum herum zählen kann.
Wir haben natürlich Meteoriten vom Mars, aber wir wissen nicht genau, wo sie herkommen.
Und dann kann ich zwar die Meteoriten radiometrisch datieren,
aber ich kann meine Kraterzählung nicht durchführen, weil ich nicht weiß,
woher stammt dieser Meteorit.
Das heißt auch die ganzen Rover der Amerikaner auf dem Mars sind nicht in der
Lage, so eine Messung durchzuführen.
Nein, genau. Das können die nicht. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel jetzt mittlerweile
Überlegungen, wie man vor Ort sogenannte in situ radiometrische Altersbestimmung macht.
Das ist ein Instrument, das von einem Kollegen aus Amerika für eine Mission vorgeschlagen ist.
Und die sollen dann tatsächlich auf dem Mond radiometrisch diese Alter bestimmen.
Das ist natürlich dann nochmal eine extrem spannende Möglichkeit,
weil ich dann eben vielleicht mit mehreren Landemissionen eben auch unterschiedliche Gebiete….
Und man muss es nicht erst wieder.
Zurückbringen. Man muss es nicht zurückbringen. Andererseits wieder,
muss ich sagen, diese Mondproben…,
Die sind einfach fantastisch, weil Sie können sich vorstellen,
die sind Ende der 60er, Anfang der 70er Jahre mit auf die Erde gebracht worden,
aber unsere analytischen Fähigkeiten haben sie natürlich in diesen 50 Jahren so stark verbessert.
Wo man früher große Mengen an Material braucht hat, reichen heute ein paar Milligramm dazu.
Und generell lassen sich heute Nachweisgrenzen natürlich immer weiter nach unten drücken.
Und wir sehen viele, viele Sachen, die wir in den 60er und 70er Jahren noch
gar nicht haben detektieren können.
Klassisches Beispiel, Wasser auf dem Mond, hat vor ein paar Jahren ein sehr,
sehr tolles Paper von Alberto Saal gegeben.
Der kleine vulkanische Kügelchen untersucht hat und in diesen Kügelchen eben
Wassereinschlüsse gefunden hat und eben daraus schließen konnten,
dass der Mond eigentlich viel reicher an Wasser ist, als man sich das ursprünglich vorgestellt hat.
Ja, räumen wir das Thema doch auch gleich mal ab. Also was...
Weiß man denn jetzt über den Mond?
Mich würde vor allem mal interessieren, was man so in den letzten 10,
15 Jahren dazu noch dazu gelernt hat aus diesen letzten Missionen oder eben
aus diesen nachgelagerten Untersuchungen der bisherigen Missionen und anderen Beobachtungen.
Wie schlau sind wir denn jetzt sozusagen überhaupt über die Beschaffenheit des
Mondes wir wissen da liegt da ganz viel Regolith rum und keine Atmosphäre also.
Alles bleibt so eine ewige Datenbank aber,
Wasser war ja lange Zeit ein großes Fragezeichen ob es überhaupt welches gibt
und wenn ja in welchen Mengen und wo was ist denn da jetzt an Erkenntnissen dazugekommen?
Tatsächlich ist es immer noch ein großes Fragezeichen. Also wir haben natürlich
mittlerweile sehr gute Hinweise darauf, dass es tatsächlich Wasser speziell
an den Polen gibt und speziell an den Polen in Kratern,
wo der Kraterboden im permanenten Schatten liegt.
Also sprich, die Sonne kommt nicht mehr so hoch über den Horizont an den Polen,
dass Sonnenlicht auf den Kraterboden fallen könnte.
Und jetzt sind wir auf einem atmosphärenlosen Körper unterwegs.
Das heißt, wenn ich dort im Schatten bin, dann ist es sehr, sehr kalt und wir
erreichen tatsächlich extrem niedrige Temperaturen, minus 250 Grad, so plus minus.
Und dort kann also Wassereis und auch andere leichtflüchtige Stoffe können dort
ausfrieren und können über geologisch lange Zeiträume auch erhalten bleiben.
Was heißt, man hat Hinweise darauf?
Genau, also wir hatten erstmal Radardaten und da hat man eben festgestellt,
dass wenn man über diese Pole fliegt, dass einige von diesen Kratern sehr hohe
Radarsignale zurückschmeißen.
Und das wird eben im Regelfall,
als Wassereis interpretiert. Das findet man auch auf dem Merkur übrigens.
Es ist auch erstaunlich, dass der Merkur, der so nah an der Sonne dran ist,
trotzdem an den Polen Gebiete hat, die ähnlich kalt sind und auch dort Wassereis
unter Umständen auftreten kann.
Also diese Radardaten der Clementine-Mission, das waren so die ersten,
meines Wissens die ersten Hinweise.
Clementine?
Genau. Auch natürlich hat man in den Apollo-Proben schon mal Hinweise auf Wasser
gefunden, aber man hat damals einfach gedacht, es sei Kontamination,
dass man da irgendwie das Wasser eigentlich von der Erde kommt,
weil man es sich einfach nicht vorstellen hat können.
Gut, nachdem Clementine diese ersten Hinweise geliefert hat,
ist mal ein Neutronenspektrometer geflogen auf Lunar Prospector und dieses Neutronenspektrometer
kann letztendlich Wasserstoff detektieren und da hat man auch in den Polgebieten
eben erhöhte Wasserstoffkonzentrationen feststellen können.
Man hat allerdings jetzt nicht sagen können, ob das jetzt Wasser ist oder ob
es eben nur Wasserstoff ist.
Und ja, irgendwann ist mit dem Start von dem Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter ist
ja auch das LCROSS-Raumschiff mitgeflogen.
Und das hat man bewusst eben am Südpol einschlagen lassen,
beziehungsweise die Oberstufe der Rakete und dieses Raumschiff hat dann eben
dieses ausgeworfene Material untersuchen können spektral und hat da ungefähr
so 5-6% Wasser eben in dieser Auswurfwolke detektiert.
Also Clementine ist eine Mission von 94 von den Amerikanern.
Und Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter ist so seit 2009 ungefähr unterwegs.
Genau. Und da ist eben,
Das Hauptziel mit dem Lunar-Iconicens-Orbiter, oder eines der Ziele,
die Pole auch genau zum Untersuchen.
Also sprich, wo genau treten diese permanent im Schatten liegenden Gebiete auf?
Und die haben wir natürlich mittlerweile sehr, sehr gut und genau kartiert,
weil wir eben schon seit 2009 im Orbit sind und sehr oft rüberfliegen.
Ja, es hat dann noch die ein oder andere Mission gegeben.
Aber was wir eben nicht wissen, ist tatsächlich, wie viel Wasser es dort gibt
an den Polen, wie es auftritt.
Also ist es jetzt nur azubiertes Wasser an der Oberfläche?
Sind es größere Eislinsen, die im Regolith eben verborgen sind?
Wie tief sind sie verborgen?
Ist das Eis vielleicht nur im Porenraum
zwischen den Regolithpartikelchen enthalten? wie rein ist es, also,
Wenn man an der Mondbasis denkt, dann will man natürlich die Ressourcen vor
Ort möglichst gut nutzen.
Alles, was ich nicht von der Erde zum Mond schleppen muss, macht meine Mission
billiger und effektiver.
Aber man muss dann eben verstehen, wie kann ich das Wasser gewinnen?
Wie muss ich es behandeln, damit es auch überhaupt vielleicht trinkbar wird für die Astronauten?
Das sind so Fragen, die eigentlich noch relativ ungeklärt sind.
Weiß man denn, dass es sich um normales Wasser handelt? Es kann ja auch ein
schweres Wasser sein, also auf Teuterium basieren.
Also das ist ein normales Wasser, also ich habe jetzt noch nichts gehört,
dass das… H2O. Ja, genau.
Und auch auf jeden Fall nicht Bakterien versorgt.
Ich meine, das ist ja immer eine Mischung, ja. Aber es ist jetzt kein schweres
Wasser, wie man es sich so vorstellt, in einem Kernreaktor oder so.
Okay, also durch diese ganzen Missionen hat man erst die Hinweise bekommen,
da ist erstmal irgendwas wässriges da hat man genauer hingeschaut und festgestellt wir gehen.
Nicht davon aus, dass es flüssig ist.
Ja, also wässrig im Sinne von,
du hast ja gesagt, es reflektiert das ist ja nur Radar,
normalerweise hat man den Regolith, den kann man wahrscheinlich relativ gut
rausfühlen Steine dann wahrscheinlich auch und dann bleibt ja nicht mehr so richtig viel übrig,
weil jetzt so Edelstahlplatten oder sowas sind da wahrscheinlich eh nicht zu
finden das ist also sozusagen einfach Das ist einfach eine Schlussfolgerung
aus dem, was man sieht, die recht wahrscheinlich ist.
Aber das heißt, es gibt bisher auch noch keine Mission, die jetzt wirklich einen
Touchdown gehabt hat und die auf Wasser gestoßen ist.
Also diese L-Cross-Mission ist gestoßen, indem sie eingeschlagen.
Aber wir haben jetzt noch keine Probe genommen.
Das haben wir tatsächlich noch nicht gemacht. Das wäre aber jetzt eigentlich
dann der nächste Schritt.
Und dieses Wasser treibt natürlich genau das Design von solchen Missionen vorwärts.
Alle Nationen, die zum Mond fliegen wollen, haben ein sehr großes Interesse
an diesem möglichen Wasservorkommen.
Ob das jetzt die NASA ist, ob das private Anbieter sind, ob es Indien ist,
die auch schon am Polen gelandet sind.
Die Chinesen, also quer durch die Bank, alles was momentan in der Mondforsche
unterwegs ist, hat ein Interesse an den Polen.
Genau, dann sprechen wir nochmal über dieses Interesse. Warum ist jetzt auf
einmal der Mond so wieder drin?
Wir haben jetzt gerade die Artemis-Mission, der Amerikaner.
Die jetzt eine erste und jetzt im Prinzip auch eine zweite Testphase durchhaben.
Also was heißt Testphase, die sind da hingeflogen, diesmal sogar mit Personal,
weil es ja eine bemannte Mission ist nach langer, langer Zeit,
eben seitdem man halt in den 60er Jahren da mal zum Mond gekommen ist,
ist dann nachher das Interesse so ein bisschen erloschen.
Alle so, ja, Mond und so, noch eine Mondlandung.
Hat sich dann die Begeisterung hat sich dann da doch schnell gelegt.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist jetzt glaube ich dieses Interesse wieder neu aufgeflammt
aber es ist ja jetzt nicht dasselbe Interesse wie damals, wo es überhaupt das
erste Mal gelingen musste,
wo es ja an sich sozusagen eine der Menschheitsträume,
schlechthin war und man sich das ja kaum vorstellen konnte, dass man überhaupt
den Planeten verlassen konnte, dann war es halt auf einmal möglich,
jetzt reden wir wieder mehr über Mars hat nochmal seine ganz anderen Herausforderungen,
müssen wir jetzt nicht drüber sprechen.
Aber was ist jetzt so der Hauptgrund, warum der Mond wieder so in den Fokus
geraten ist der ganzen Space-Industrie?
Also ich denke, der Mond ist halt ein wirklich sehr wichtiger Körper,
Also wissenschaftlich gesehen, aber eben auch als Körper, wo man Technologien
testen kann, wie du gerade gesagt hast, um zum Beispiel dann irgendwann bemannt
Richtung Mars sich auf den Weg zu machen.
Wenn man zum Mars fliegen will, glaube ich, kommt man um den Mond nicht drumherum.
Also man kann sich auch durchaus vorstellen, dass es Sinn macht,
zum Beispiel dieses Wasser auf dem Mond, wenn es in genügender Menge vorhanden
ist, zu gewinnen, zu spalten.
Habe ich Sauerstoff, habe ich Wasserstoff, ist eigentlich der ideale Raketentreibstoff.
Und mit der geringen Anziehungskraft des Mondes kann ich natürlich viel größere
Raketen leichter starten und viel mehr Material Richtung Mars schicken letztendlich.
Also wenn man das direkt macht von der Erde aus, wird es sehr, sehr schwer.
Also alles, was mit Technologieentwicklung zu tun hat,
wie landet man auf dem Körper, wie koppelt man Raumschiffe, wie versorge ich
Raumschiffe, wie kann ich Astronauten
für mindestens ein halbes Jahr Richtung Mars am Leben erhalten.
All solche Dinge müssen erst mal getestet werden. Und ich glaube,
da ist der Mond ein sehr, sehr gutes Testbed, wie man es so schön auf Englisch sagt.
Und ich bin ja jetzt Wissenschaftler, also ich habe enorm viele Fragen über den Mond.
Als Doktorand dachte ich auch, wie du vorher gerade gesagt hast,
war man ja mit zwölf Astronauten, weiß man doch alles.
Also ich habe da am Anfang auch meine Probleme gehabt, um das meinen Freunden
zum Beispiel immer zu erklären, warum man jetzt auch Geld dafür ausgeben muss.
Aber heute ist es eigentlich genau das Gegenteil.
Ich denke, man wird das Erde-Mond-System nicht verstehen können und damit auch
unser ganzes Sonnensystem nicht verstehen können, wenn man nicht den Mond erforscht.
Auf der Erde sehe ich nur die letzten, sagen wir mal, eineinhalb Milliarden
Jahren des Sonnensystementwicklung.
Alle anderen Gesteine sind vernichtet. Und der Mond füllt mir genau diese Lücke.
Da kann ich die ersten drei, vier Milliarden Jahre des Sonnensystementwicklung
letztendlich erforschen.
Und das ist der Knackpunkt. Und das kann auf vielen Ebenen passieren.
Das kann über die Einschlagsrate sein, was wir vorher diskutiert haben.
Wie genau funktioniert das, wie hat es sich vulkanisch entwickelt.
Das Wasser untersuchen, ich kann untersuchen, wie ist der innere Aufbau von
diesem Mond, haben wir auch noch Fragen.
Eine fundamental wichtige Frage ist, wie sie überhaupt entstanden,
stimmt diese Hypothese mit diesem Giant Impact, wo ungefähr Mars großer Körper
eben auf die sehr frühe Erde eingeschlagen ist, stimmt das überhaupt?
Also das ist ja ein Konzept,
das aus den Apollo-Daten letztendlich abgeleitet worden ist,
Aber wo man heutzutage eben über die detaillierte Analyse von diesen Gesteinen
eigentlich schon nochmal die Sache hinterfragen muss, weil Mond und Erde eben so ähnlich sind.
Dass das mit dieser Einschlagshypothese nicht unbedingt hundertprozentig zusammenpasst.
Also da muss man nochmal nachdenken, da muss man neu forschen.
Und selbst für Astronomen ist der Mond hochspannend, weil er hat ja gebundene
Rotation, das heißt, er zeigt uns immer eine Seite.
Und ich könnte mir so gut vorstellen, ein Radioteleskop auf der Mondabgewandenseite,
um ins Universum in Anführungszeichen zu lauschen,
ist natürlich fantastisch, weil auf der Mondrückseite bin ich von unserem ganzen
Handy geschnattert, bin ich abgeschottet,
da habe ich im Radiowellenlängenbereich sehr, sehr ruhige Verhältnisse und ich
kann dementsprechend viel, viel besser ins Weltall lauschen,
als ich das von hier aus der Erde aus machen könnte oder von einem Raumschiff
machen könnte, das um die Erde kreist.
Also da bin ich immer noch in dieser Radioblase der Erde drin.
Da muss man nur ein Teleskop gebaut bekommen, was diesen doch recht widrigen
Umgebungstemperaturen mal sehr heiß, mal sehr kalt, nennenswert,
was entgegensetzen kann.
Und man muss auch noch eine Methode finden, wie man die Daten wieder zurück
holt. Aber das braucht man wahrscheinlich über die Orbiter dann.
Auch da wird natürlich viel drüber nachgedacht. Also auch China hat ja einen
Kommunikationssatelliten um den Mond.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er jetzt noch funktioniert, aber sie hatten zumindest einen.
Und natürlich denkt auch die ESA darüber nach.
Kommunikationsnetzwerk letztendlich aufzubauen. Das ist ja auch wichtig,
wenn ich gewisse Mobilität auf der Oberfläche haben will,
kann man sich auch vorstellen, dass das natürlich über so eine Art Mond-GPS-System
natürlich dann viel besser funktioniert, als wenn die Astronauten sich an irgendwelchen
Landmarken orientieren müssen.
Also es wäre natürlich praktisch, wenn der ähnlich wie, wenn man es heute hier
auf der Erde auch macht, sein Handy rauszieht und sofort sieht,
wo er gerade unterwegs ist.
Also ja, Datenrate ist immer bei jeder Raumfahrtmission ein Problem,
aber es ist kein Problem, das wir nicht irgendwie lösen könnten.
Und ich glaube, der Wissensgebung von so einem Radioteleskop auf der Rückseite,
die Kosten wahrscheinlich lange wettmachen.
Ich weiß, dass das nicht so dein Gebiet ist, aber was sind denn derzeit so die
aktuellen Missionen, die eigentlich Daten liefern und was ist so in,
unmittelbarer Zukunft geplant, was das noch ergänzen soll?
Also das war ja eben so mit dem GPS, das war ja sozusagen nur so ein,
müsste man mal machen, das ist ja jetzt noch nicht konkret geplant,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, aber was liefert denn derzeit uns Daten vom Mond?
Also es ist insofern geplant, dass es meines Wissens in der Raumfahrtstrategie
der ESA mit drinsteht und natürlich auch andere Nationen ähnliche Gedanken haben.
Aber was geht momentan gerade ab auf den Mond? Da ist zum einen mit Sicherheit
zum Nennen dieser Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter.
Von der NASA.
Genau. Ich bin an dem beteiligt, also ich war schon bei dem Entwurf von dieser
Kamera, also ich bin an den Kameras beteiligt,
an dem Entwurf der Kameras beteiligt und ja, wir fliegen eben seit 2009 um den Mond.
Wir haben zwei große Teleskopkameras dabei,
so 70 Zentimeter Brennweite, 27 Zentimeter Durchmesser und wir fliegen ungefähr
50 Kilometer so im Schnitt, ja mal ein bisschen niedriger, mal ein bisschen
höher, aber so im Schnitt um die 50 Kilometer über der Mondoberfläche.
Wir schauen senkrecht nach unten und wir kriegen eine Bildauflösung von ungefähr
einem halben Meter auf einem halben Meter. Ja, das ist fantastisch.
Es sind, ich glaube, mittlerweile, ich weiß jetzt die Zahl nicht genau, 13 oder 16.
Petabyte an Daten, die wir vom Mond haben. Also mit weitem, weitem,
weitem Abstand produziert LRO mehr Daten als alle anderen Missionen zusammen.
Und das erlaubt uns natürlich völlig neue Einblicke in den Mond.
Wir sehen eben die kleinsten Krater, buchstäblicher.
Wir sehen Strukturen, die man vielleicht in den Elterndaten erahnen hat,
können sie immer jetzt sehen mit hoher Präzision.
Und eine sehr, sehr gute Auflösung und das ist natürlich fantastisch.
Wir haben natürlich nicht nur die Kameras an Bord, sondern wir haben Laseraltimeter,
das leider nicht mehr funktioniert, aber viele andere Instrumente,
zum Beispiel die Weiner,
das die Temperatur auf dem Mond eben vermisst, hochpräzise vermisst.
Das sind wichtige Daten, um zum Beispiel diese Gebiete von permanent im Schatten
liegenden Kraterböden zum Finden und dann auch diese minus 250 Grad erst mal zu messen.
Es sind mit die kältesten Temperaturen im ganzen Sonnensystem,
die man auf dem Mond eben bestimmt hat und gemessen hat. Also das ist natürlich...
Einfach toll. Wir haben natürlich jede Menge Missionen mittlerweile,
die von China betrieben worden sind. Changi ist da das Stichwort.
Wir sind ja jetzt bei Changi 7, die nächstes Jahr, glaube ich,
oder noch dieses Jahr, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht so genau, noch starten sollen.
Ich glaube, Changi ist nächstes Jahr.
Oder? Oder ist 8 nächstes Jahr? Ist egal, ja.
Es sind auf jeden Fall schon so einige unterwegs, ich schaue.
Das ist natürlich auch so, haben die Chinesen durchaus mittlerweile Probenrückführung
gemacht, also robotische Probenrückführung.
Das ist schon eine Meisterleistung, speziell auch von der Mondrückseite.
Die fahren dort oben mit Mondautos, Mondrovers durch die Gegend,
haben tolle Instrumente. und woanders in den letzten zehn Jahren wirklich auf
einer extrem steilen Lernkurve.
Also man braucht sich nicht einbilden, dass China nur Instrumente nachbaut oder Missionen nachfliegt.
Aus der Zeit sind wir lange raus. Die entwickeln extrem gute Missionen und sie
haben vor allem ein sehr gutes Mondprogramm, wo ein Schritt auf den nächsten aufbaut.
Geht was schief, dann wird es eben verbessert, wird wieder geflogen und das
ist ja eine ganz logische Entwicklung einfach.
Letzte Mission war die Fünfer, Chang'e 5 und geplant ist jetzt 6, 7, 8.
6 soll umkreisen, 7 soll landen und 8 soll zurückkehren, wenn ich das hier richtig deute.
Ja, ich dachte, ja, okay.
Sagt die Wikipedia, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt. Da können die Leute ja alles reinschreiben.
Okay, also das Interesse ist bei der ESA da, bei der NASA da,
also im Prinzip eigentlich bei nahezu allen Organisationen. JAXA wahrscheinlich.
JAXA auf alle Fälle, ja.
Die haben es ja eh so mit Asteroiden und so.
JAXA hat natürlich auch ihre eigene Mondmission in den 90er Jahren geflogen oder 2000 irgendwie so.
Die Selene-Mission, Selene-Kaguya. Auch eine sehr, sehr erfolgreiche Mission
mit einem tollen Spektrometer auch und einer sehr, sehr guten Kamera.
Sind denn diese Daten auch alle öffentlich verfügbar eigentlich?
Ja, tatsächlich. Auch das ist einmalig in der Planetologie, dass alle Daten,
Mehr oder weniger nach einem halben Jahr einfach veröffentlicht werden und damit
jedem zu freien Downloads zur Verfügung stehen. Man muss also nicht dafür zahlen.
Wenn ich eher Daten haben will, zahle ich dafür und das finde ich ganz billig.
Ja, da sollte man mal Google Bescheid sagen, weil wenn ich bei Google erst auf
den Mond umschalte, dann bin ich da definitiv nicht bei einem halben Meter Auflösung
angekommen, sondern es ist alles noch ein bisschen schwammig, würde ich sagen.
Das kann sein, aber es gibt genügend Webseiten auch Quick Map,
wo Sie viele, viele Datensätze einfach anklicken können und reinzoomen können,
den Mond drehen können und da haben Sie extrem gute Auflösung auch und Sie können
sich wirklich jedes Bild vom Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter einfach runterladen
und können sich das auf Ihrem Computer anschauen.
Und das sind exakt die gleichen Daten, mit denen wir auch unsere Wissenschaft machen.
Wir haben lediglich den Vorteil, dass wir die Daten ungefähr ein halbes Jahr
früher kriegen, bevor sie veröffentlicht werden.
Weil natürlich auch so ein Raumschiff, da steckt ja viel Arbeit drin.
Und darum kriegen wir Wissenschaftler dann ein halbes Jahr so Karenzzeit,
um unsere Wissenschaft zu machen, unsere Papers zu schreiben,
bevor sie dann wirklich….
Bevor das jeder machen kann.
Genau. Und natürlich gibt es genügend Mondwissenschaftler, die nicht an dieser
Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter Mission beteiligt sind und die natürliche Interesse
daran haben, diese Daten möglichst schnell zu bekommen.
Und ja, es ist prinzipiell so, dass diese Daten frei verfügbar sind über die
entsprechenden Webseiten.
Das Gleiche gilt auch für China. Ich kann auch Mondproben aus China anfordern.
Die teilen ihre Proben genauso, wie es die NASA teilt.
Die haben ein ähnliches Verfahren. Ich muss halt einen Antrag schreiben,
muss beschreiben, was ich machen will, ob die Probe dabei kaputt geht.
Für manche chemische Analysen muss ich sie eben auflösen, dann gibt es die Probe halt nicht mehr.
Aber wenn die wissenschaftliche Fragestellung eben gut ist und gut begründet
ist, dann kriege ich auch aus China Proben und viele meiner Kollegen haben diese
Proben auch schon bekommen.
Es sind ja noch ein paar andere Länder mit dabei, ich glaube auch Indien hat
noch eine Orbitette unterwegs.
Indien ist am Südpol gelandet, ja genau. Das ist auch erstmal sehr schwierig
zu machen, am Südpol zu landen.
Und ja, also die Vereinigten Emirate planen einen Mondrover.
Auch das ist ein sehr, sehr spannendes Thema. Der hat auch einige Instrumente an Bord.
Also es ist dann eben nicht nur so, dass man als Nation zeigen will,
dass man das kann. Da steckt sicher einige Motivation dahinter, ist ganz klar.
Aber es werden eben auch versucht, wissenschaftliche Fragen zu beantworten.
Und wieder das Wasser ist natürlich schon eine wesentliche Motivation.
Südkorea ist auch glaube ich mit.
Südkorea es fliegt diesen kplo also fantastische kamera an bord die hochsensitiv ist,
Die erlaubt es mir tatsächlich, in diese permanent im Schatten liegenden Gebiete
zu schauen, um eben dort zu sehen, ob das Wasser als direkt an der Oberfläche liegt.
Dann wäre es eben hell, sage ich mal.
Oder ob es eben unter einer Staubschicht zum Beispiel bedeckt ist.
Ich kann mir die Strukturen in diesen Kratern anschauen, weil wenn viel Eis im Boden ist,
ja dann könnte man sich auch vorstellen dass zum beispiel steile krater
ränder anfangen zu rutschen und es
also so hangrutsch ähnliche strukturen gibt
die über das eis mobilisiert werden also solche dinge kann ich gletscher im
prinzip ja jetzt naiv gesagt ja so rock glasher wird man es vielleicht als erst
noch so als analog bezeichnen können ja also ja das das sind eben.
Ein genereller Wandel, der sich in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren vollzogen hat,
dass auch relativ kleine Nationen mit einem überschaubaren Budget zum Mond fliegen
können und dort tolle Wissenschaft betreiben können.
Und das ist natürlich auch von einem philosophischen Standpunkt her wichtig,
weil den Mond kann ich von der Erde aus, gut, wenn nicht gerade Neumond ist,
eigentlich immer sehen.
Und das macht was mit dem Menschen. Das ist völlig anders, wenn ich den Mond
eben sehen kann und ich weiß, geht mir ja auch so,
jetzt in dem Moment kreist mein Raumschiff da oben rum oder es ist gelandet
und es fährt gerade von dem Krater zu dem Krater. Das macht was mit Menschen.
Also wenn ich einen kleinen Planeten habe, den ich vielleicht nur als Lichtpunkt
sehe, da tue ich mir einfach schwerer, mir das vorzustellen,
wie da ein Rover auf der Oberfläche fliegt.
Also da ist der Mond eben.
Es ist gut, dass er direkt vor der Haustür liegt, sage ich mal.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass die Leute keine emotionale Verbindung zum
Mars haben, aber es stimmt natürlich, dass der Mond da nochmal in einer anderen Liga spielt.
Jetzt haben wir diese Orbiter-Missionen angesprochen, die also jetzt unterwegs
sind, also China, Chang'e 5 ist auch noch im Betrieb glaube ich,
Indien mit diesem Chandrayaan heißt er glaube ich Orbiter, Südkorea,
genau und die NASA und die ESA hat derzeit nichts im Orbit.
Und momentan tatsächlich nichts, also keine eigene Mission.
ESA hat viele Instrumente auf anderen, auch kommerziellen Missionen unterbracht.
Es war jetzt in der letzten Zeit eben sehr schwierig.
In dem politischen Umfeld, das wir momentan gerade in Amerika haben,
eine kohärente Strategie zum Entwickeln.
Ich habe da das Vergnügen, auch
am Rande mitarbeiten zu dürfen und das war wirklich sehr, sehr schwierig.
Aber ich denke mal, mit diesem Kommunikationssystem, das wir dort installieren wollen von ESA-Seite,
wir haben natürlich auch als Beistellung für die Artemis-Mission diesen Argonaut-Lander.
Das ist also letztendlich eine Landefähre, die Astronauten auf der Oberfläche
mit Versorgungsgütern unterstützen soll, versorgen soll.
Aber man kann sich eben auch vorstellen, dass dieser Argonat-Lander eben auch
für wissenschaftliche Zwecke nutzbar wird, weil eben gedacht ist,
dass man den alle paar Jahre dann zum Beispiel fliegen kann.
Also das wäre dann nicht eine einzelne Mission, so nach dem Motto einmal hinfliegen und dann war es das,
sondern man würde das Raumschiff eben wiederverwenden und alle zwei,
drei Jahre, je nachdem wie die Finanzlage halt auch ist, könnte man das wiederverwenden
und eben wissenschaftliche Missionen dann auffliegen.
Okay, das waren also jetzt die Orbiter, die wir angeschaut haben.
Es gibt ja auch noch einen Rover auf dem Mond, den U-2-2 von den Chinesen.
Und der Fetter auch noch.
Ja, soviel ich weiß.
Da weiß man wenig drüber. Oder sagen wir mal,
es ist nicht so im kulturellen Hivemind unserer Gesellschaft abgespeichert,
dass die Chinesen das überhaupt geschafft haben und da permanent neue Daten liefern.
Hängst du da auch in irgendeiner Form an der Informationskette dran?
Das ist eigentlich jetzt tatsächlich überhaupt nicht drin. Also da bin ich auch
etwas blank, was der Rover kann und was er für wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse
tatsächlich bisher geliefert hat,
muss jetzt ehrlich gesagt passen.
Ja okay, aber auf jeden Fall gibt es den noch und der fährt auch noch durch
die Gegend, soweit ich weiß.
Und das schon seit gut 2600 Tagen.
Also dafür, dass es mal für drei Monate geplant war, kein schlechtes Ergebnis.
Da stehen also die Chinesen den Amerikanern in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon in nichts mehr nach.
Das ist generell aber so, dass natürlich die Ingenieure bei solchen Missionen
immer sogenannte Margins drauf rechnen.
Ja, gutes Beispiel ist auch Mars Express, da war eben auch eine Kamera von Herrn
Neukom da mit drauf, die HSC.
Und mit der Mission sind wir 2003 gestartet, wir sind 2004 in Orbit gegangen,
haben eigentlich gedacht, wir sind so ein Jahr oder maximal vielleicht zwei
Jahre unterwegs und das Ding funktioniert immer noch und liefert immer noch tolle Daten.
Ja, solange man noch genug Sprit hat, um da auch die Position zu halten natürlich.
Das sind natürlich solche Rahmenbedingungen, die müssen dann auch passen.
Jetzt gab es ja auch diverse weitere Missionen, die teilweise abgestürzt sind,
gelandet und umgekippt sind.
Also viel geht auch schief. Man konzentriert sich ja immer gerne auf das, was ist.
Du meintest ja vorhin auch, die Chinesen sind am Südpol gelandet,
das wäre ja nochmal besonders schwierig. Was ist denn daran so schwierig?
Indien ist am Südpol gelandet.
Ach, Indien. Indien, genau.
Ja, es ist eben so, dass man am Südpol eben sehr extreme Beleuchtungsbedingungen hat.
Das Licht kommt eben sehr streifend nur über den Horizont. Das heißt,
ich habe große abgeschattete Gebiete.
Und das macht natürlich die Landung schwierig. Es ist generell ein sehr raues
Gebiet mit vielen Gratern, vielen Gesteinsbrocken auch. Auch das will man nicht
unbedingt immer haben, wenn man landet.
Da versucht man immer auf einer möglichst ebenen, möglichst gesteinslosen Ebene zum Landen.
Und ja, es gehen Sachen in der Raumfahrt schief, ohne Zweifel. Das haben viele...
Nationen erfahren müssen, Israel, kommerzielle Anbieter, also die Japaner sind
auch schon gescheitert.
Space is hard.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, das gehört zum guten Ton, aber das ist einfach
inhärentes Risiko, das kann passieren.
Das Wichtige ist eben dann, dass man aus den Fehlern lernt und das das nächste Mal besser macht.
Und das sind alles Erfahrungen, die dann letztendlich natürlich auch beitragen,
Menschen sicher auf die Oberfläche zu bringen.
Das ist ja dann ein Fall, wo nichts schief gehen darf.
Da muss man die Technologie des Landens und des punktgenauen Landens,
muss man dann wirklich beherrschen, weil man will keine Astronauten dort oben verlieren.
Aber jetzt muss ich doch nochmal nachfragen hier mit den Kratern.
Das ist ja alles gleichmäßig verteilt, aber der Mond sieht ja nun wirklich nicht
so aus, als ob das alles gleichmäßig verteilt ist.
Also da am Pol, das ist der Nordpol, da ist es irgendwie richtig krass,
wenn ich das hier richtig deute, am Südpol auch.
Und dann gibt es ja auch große Flächen, wo kaum Krater sind.
Ja, diese ganzen dunklen Flächen sind natürlich viel glatter und man sieht auch
nur kleinere Krater und keine großen Krater.
Das ist genau richtig, aber das ist einfach dem geschuldet, dass diese Oberflächen,
die dunklen Gebiete viel, viel jünger sind als die hellen Gebiete auf dem Mond.
Die dunklen Gebiete sind eben erst später entstanden, nachdem sich die helle Kruste gebildet hat,
nachdem in diese helle Kruste große Einschläge passiert sind und Material ausgeworfen
worden ist und in diese Vertiefungen ist dann letztendlich dieses vulkanische
Material, diese Basalte erst reingeflossen,
wieder Kaffeine, Kaffeetasse quasi.
Okay, verstehe. Also die Verteilung ist eigentlich immer die gleiche,
aber genau daran sieht man, dass das dann eben der jüngere Bereich ist.
Und anders ausgedrückt, der Mond ist nicht gleichmäßig sozusagen vulkanisch aktiv gewesen,
sondern das hat sich auch an bestimmten Hotspots abgespielt und das sieht man
dann halt unter anderem eben auch an dieser Kraterlandschaft.
Das wirklich Spannende ist ja, auch aufgrund der Apollo-Proben gehen wir davon
aus, dass es auf dem Mond einen sogenannten Magma-Ozean gegeben hat.
Der war vielleicht 400-500 Kilometer mächtig.
Manche Leute sagen auch, dass der komplette Mond aufgeschmolzen war. Ja.
Wenn dieser Magma-Ozean zu kristallisieren beginnt, dann kristallisieren erst
mal Minerale, die viel Magnesium und Eisen enthalten.
Das sind dichte Materialien, die sinken in diesem Magma-Ozean nach unten und
bilden am Boden von diesem Ozean so Kumulate.
Dann habe ich aber immer noch die Schmelze oben drauf und wenn die dann immer
weiter abkühlt, immer weiter abkühlt und dann so 80, 90 Prozent abkühlt ist,
dann bildet sich letztendlich eine Kruste,
die aus Aluminium- und Calciumreichen Gesteinen besteht.
Und die schwemmt dann via Korken auf dieser Restschmelze auf.
Und das sind genau diese hellen Gebiete, die man heute noch auf dem Mond beobachten kann.
Also wir schauen uns wirklich die primäre Kruste an in diesen hellen Gebieten,
die sich aus diesem Magma-Ozean rauskristallisiert hat.
Und das ist natürlich fantastisch, weil diese Premiere-Kruste kann ich eigentlich
fast nur auf dem Mond in der Form studieren.
Merkur wird schon schwieriger, weil der eben auch sehr vulkanisch aktiv war,
da ist viel zerstört worden.
Venus, haben wir vorher gesagt, hat die komplette Oberfläche erneuert.
Auf dem Mars habe ich Wasser, habe auch Vulkanismus. Also da ist auch viel von
dieser Primärenkruste eigentlich überprägt oder vernichtet worden.
Und darum ist der Mond eben auch in der Beziehung wichtig, dass man dieses Konzept
des Magma-Ozeans, was passiert da genau,
dass man das auf dem Mond eben rausarbeiten kann, weil wir eben davon ausgehen
können, dass auch die anderen Planeten irgendwann solchen Magma-Ozean besessen haben.
Aber dass sich jetzt nichts mehr regt im Mond, da ist man sich einig oder weiß man das einfach nicht?
Nein, auch da ist man sich nicht einig tatsächlich. Also es gibt ein paar wenige
Stellen, wo man auf diesen dunklen Gebieten sehr, sehr eigenartige Strukturen sehen.
Die werden in der Literatur als Irregular Murray Patches bezeichnet.
Das sind also Vertiefungen mit, es schaut so aus wie wenn kleine Lavablasen
da auf der Oberfläche wären und wenn ich dort die Krater zähle,
dann komme ich auf relativ junge Alter zwischen 30 und 100 Millionen Jahren.
Das sind Alter, die sehr, sehr schwer zum Erklären sind, so junge Alter,
weil der Mond eben ein relativ kleiner Körper ist und damit schnell abkühlt.
Das heißt, die äußere rigide Schicht, was wir die Lithosphäre nennen,
wächst sehr, sehr mächtig an.
Wir gehen also heute davon aus, dass diese Lithosphäre ungefähr 1000 Kilometer dick ist.
Und durch diese äußere rigide Schicht an Vulkanismus bis an die Oberfläche zu
bringen, in so kleinräumigen Strukturen, ist extrem schwierig und sehr,
sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Also da denke ich mal, was ich auch vorher gesagt habe, kannst durchaus sein,
dass diese Altersbestimmung mit Kraterhäufigkeiten vielleicht an ihre Grenzen kommt.
Andere Leute sagen, nee, das sind alte Gebiete.
Da muss ich sagen, die Morphologie, die ich dort sehe von diesen kleinen Lavablasen,
die ist extrem scharf und scharfe Morphologie deutet im Regelfall auf den Mond
auf ein junges Alter hin,
weil die Mondoberfläche konstant bombardiert wird mit Mikrometeoriten und mit
kleinen Meteoriten auch und dementsprechend werden solche scharfen Kanten einfach
abgewettert Die werden immer flacher und irgendwann sehe ich sie auch nicht mehr.
Aber in diesen Mal-Patches sehe ich eben sehr, sehr scharf begrenzte Morphologie.
Und darum denke ich mal, sollten diese Patches schon relativ jung sein.
Aber mit 30 bis 100 Millionen im Jahr kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Also wahrscheinlich liegt die Antwort da oder die Wahrheit irgendwo dazwischen.
Aber das ist etwas, was wir nicht genau wissen, wo wir seit 2015 das erste Paper
darüber rauskommen, wo wir seitdem eben…,
Heißt diskutieren.
Ist denn der Mond im Sonnensystem das einzige Objekt seiner Art?
Also gibt es noch ein komplett sich ähnlich in der Zeit widerspielendes Objekt?
Also der Phobos zum Beispiel vom Mars, der ist wahrscheinlich auch atmosphärefrei.
Also ich denke mal so, unter dem größeren Körper ist sicher der Merkur der Körper,
der am ähnlichsten noch ist.
Also von der Morphologie her auf alle Fälle, wir sehen eben sehr stark begratete
Oberflächen, Wir sehen große Einschlagsbecken auch, die verfüllt sind mit vulkanischem Material.
Wir sehen an der nördlichen Hemisphäre das Merkur große vulkanische Ablagerungen,
große vulkanische Ebenen.
Also da würde ich sagen, ist der Merkur vielleicht der ähnlichste Körper.
Andererseits ist die Zusammensetzung der Oberfläche dann wieder sehr unterschiedlich.
Also Merkur ist deutlich eisenärmer an der Oberfläche als der Mond zum Beispiel.
Dafür hat er wieder einen sehr, sehr großen Eisen-Nickelkern,
während der Mond eben nur einen kleinen hat.
Also man muss da immer aufpassen, wenn man sagt, das ist ein Körper, der ähnlich ist.
Ja, er kann ähnlich sein in einer Beziehung, aber er kann komplett unterschiedlich
in einer anderen Beziehung sein und,
Früher mit rein astronomischen Beobachtungen hat man ja auch immer die Venus
als Schwesterplanet der Erde bezeichnet, aber wenn man mal genau hinschaut, ist es nicht so.
Okay, aber Merkur und Mond sind eigentlich, sagen wir mal, für dieses,
wie war das Universum früher durch Betrachtung von diesen Objekten eigentlich
die interessanteste Quelle?
Ja, also zumindest Sonnensystem, ja.
Genau, ich meine woanders kommen wir ja erstmal nicht hin.
Bin schon noch gespannt auf ein paar andere Missionen, aber das liegt halt alles nicht so nah. Ja,
es gibt ja ein Phänomen, das nennt sich Lunar Transient Phänomena,
also so eine Art Blitz, Lichtblitz, den man wahrnimmt vom Mond.
Ist der Mond doch bewohnt?
Kommen wir doch jetzt mal wirklich auf die interessante Sache.
Okay, jetzt wird es wirklich interessant. Das alles war ja nur vorgebringend.
Ich glaube, wir können uns relativ sicher sein, dass der Mond nicht bewohnt ist.
Aber diese Lichtblitze, die gibt es tatsächlich.
Wir haben die jetzt auch mit Artemis II zum Beispiel nochmal beobachtet,
wo tatsächlich auch Krater auf der Mondoberfläche sich gebildet haben.
Und wenn so ein Krater sich bildet, da wird sehr viel kinetische Energie übertragen
und die sieht man dann eben auch als Lichtblitzer, diese Krater.
Das heißt, Lichtblitze sind Einschläge in dem Moment, wo sie stattfinden?
Ja, genau. Diese Transient-Phänomena, die von den Astronauten beobachtet worden
sind, sind vielleicht nochmal was anderes.
Da geht die Wissenschaft immer noch, sage ich mal...
Ja, teilweise werden sie ignoriert, sage ich mal. Man kann sie nicht wirklich
erklären, meines Wissens.
Es können auch optische Täuschungen gewesen sein. Aber die Lichtblitze sieht
man tatsächlich und wir hatten auch mit unserem Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter
Aufnahmen von einem gewissen Gebiet auf dem Mond gemacht,
von dem dann ein paar Monate später so ein Lichtblitz eben beobachtet worden ist.
Und nachdem wir nach wie vor im Orbit sind, sind wir irgendwann über diese gleiche
Stelle wiedergekommen und haben tatsächlich dann einen neuen Krater gesehen,
der so 18 Meter im Durchmesser gehabt hat.
Und wir waren damals unwahrscheinlich aufgeregt. Wir haben gesehen quasi,
wie sich ein neuer Krater bildet.
Mittlerweile haben wir eben viele, viele Hunderte von solchen Kratern,
die sich gebildet haben, während wir im Orbit um den Mond waren.
Und wir sind ja auch nicht die kleinsten, sondern nur eine bestimmte Größe.
Also man sieht wirklich den Einschlag in dem Moment, wo er erfolgt?
Genau, das wäre der Lichtblitz. Aber was wir dann natürlich sehen,
ist die Oberfläche vor dem Einschlag.
Und dann, wenn wir zum zweiten Mal drüber fliegen, sehen wir eben den Krater,
der sich bei dem Einschlag gebildet hat.
Aber warum gibt es einen Lichtblitz? Weil einfach die Energien,
die in dem Moment so groß sind.
Das heißt, er funkelt eigentlich.
Die wichtige Nachricht ist eigentlich, dass das ein völlig normaler Prozess ist.
Also es war eben nicht nur dieser eine Krater, den wir beobachtet haben,
sondern viele hunderte Krater, die wir seitdem beobachtet haben,
die sich auf dem Mond gebildet haben.
Das heißt aber im Umkehrschluss auch für die Erde, dieses Erde-Mond-System wird
nach wie vor bombardiert.
Und der Mond erlaubt uns eben,
rauszufinden, wie stark dieses Bombardement ist, wie die Größenverteilungen
der Projektile sind, die bei uns in diesem Erdem-Mond-System ankommen.
Der Erde verglüht eben sehr viel, Gott sei Dank, in der Atmosphäre,
aber ab und zu dringt eben doch was durch.
Chelyabinsk oder jetzt vor ein paar Wochen oder zwei Monate her Koblenz,
wo ihm sein Meteoritenfall passiert ist. Das ist ja nichts anderes.
Wo ist der nochmal runtergekommen?
Koblenz.
Ja, aber ist er nicht irgendwo auch richtig eingeschlagen in ein Haus?
War das das? Oder verwechsel ich das gerade?
Also Celia Binz war das halt in Russland, wo man ganz viele Aufnahmen von hatte,
weil der relativ groß war und dann gab es auch diese Druckwelle und Verletze
und so weiter. Da ist schon richtig was los, ja.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir noch mal den anderen Elefanten im Raum,
also die Diskussion über Mondbasen.
Also wir hatten ja schon angesprochen, dass es interessant ist,
den Mond einfach als Zwischenbahnhof zu benutzen, um andere Missionen zu starten.
Erstmal kann man dort halt mit kleineren Missionen, Transportmissionen erstmal
Material hinbringen oder vielleicht eben auch eine andere Rakete hinbringen,
die man dann eben mit deutlich weniger Energieaufwand starten kann. Das wissen wir ja auch.
Ich meine, die Astronauten sind ja nicht nur auf dem Mond gelandet,
sondern sind ja auch wieder zurückgekehrt.
Das heißt, das konnten sie mit relativ wenig Aufwand machen,
während man ja riesige Raketen braucht, um überhaupt eine Mission überhaupt
erstmal von der Erde wegzubekommen. Ganz klar, weil der Mond natürlich viel
kleiner ist und deutlich weniger Gravitation hat.
Eigentlich habe ich die Befürchtung, dass da deutlich mehr Staub aufgewirbelt
wird, wenn man das macht, was ja auch nochmal ein Problem sein könnte.
Überhaupt dieser ganze Gedanke, dass der Mond eigentlich so als perfektes Spiegelbild
von Millionen Jahren von Geschichte und Entwicklung und Universum in dem Moment,
wo dann halt nicht nur ein paar Röber fahren,
sondern halt richtig Alarm gemacht wird und quasi industriell genutzt wird,
natürlich sein Bild dann auch für immer ändern wird.
Sicherlich auch ein Aspekt, der gemacht wird. Aber mal davon abgesehen,
von der Mond-Umweltbewegung.
Wie realistisch ist es denn überhaupt, so eine Mondbasis zu bauen? Was ist da angedacht?
Wie würde man denn sowas überhaupt bewerkstelligen? Wissen wir überhaupt schon
genug, um so etwas durchführen zu können?
Also realistisch glaube ich ja. Also ich denke, wir können das.
Man muss es im Wollen auch und entsprechend finanziell ausstatten.
Von wissenschaftlicher Seite her und auch von technologischer Seite,
glaube ich, macht es Sinn, permanent auf dem Mond zu sein.
Also man kann einfach einen Körper viel, viel besser und effektiver studieren.
Wenn ich einmal den Flug gemacht habe, der wirklich Geld kostet,
und wenn ich dann ein Habitat habe auf der Mondoberfläche, dann kann ich da natürlich...
Viel weiter mit dem Rover fahren, vor allem wenn er eine Druckkabine hat und so weiter.
Also wir werden da mit Sicherheit sehr, sehr viel über den Mond lernen können,
wenn ich so eine Mondbasis habe.
Wo bauen wir die jetzt hin? Das ist natürlich die Gretchenfrage.
Ich hätte eine Vermutung. Naja, also Pol, weil sonst hat man das Problem,
dass immer zwei Wochen lang Licht und zwei Wochen dunkel ist und auch kein Verkehr.
Also müsste man dahin kommen, wo es so ein bisschen, ich weiß gar nicht,
ist das dann so gräulich oder rotiert das dann die ganze Zeit?
Wir haben tatsächlich eben hunderte von Bildern oder tausende von Bildern übereinander
gelegt und haben untersucht, wo die Sonne permanent hinscheint.
Das ist ja sehr wichtig, weil ich dann zur Basis eben ganz simpel gesprochen
mit Sonnenpanelen betreiben kann, wenn ich mehr oder weniger immer dem Sonnenlicht ausgesetzt bin.
Also solche Orte gibt es sozusagen?
Die gibt es tatsächlich, zum Beispiel am Rand von so einem Shackleton-Krat am Südpol.
Also das wäre eine gute...
Stelle für eine Mondbasis, einfach weil ich damit mein Energieproblem gelöst habe.
Überall anders, wie du sagst, sitze ich 14 Tage im Schatten und muss dementsprechend
eben entweder große Batterien laden, während ich in der Sonne bin,
oder ich brauche irgendwelche,
Radiosotop-Batterien.
Und die Heizkosten. Das macht es natürlich schon schwieriger.
Pole sind natürlich eine gute.
Möglichkeit, vor allem, weil ich eben dann in unmittelbarer Nähe auch von Wasservorkommen
bin und wenn wir sichergestellt haben, dass dieses Wasser auch zugänglich ist,
dass ich es auch nutzen kann,
dann schlage ich natürlich schon mal zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe,
nämlich mein Energieproblem und ein Versorgungsproblem von meinen Astronauten.
Und alles, was ich eben nicht von der Erde mitschleppen muss,
macht meine Missionen besser.
Ich mache immer so einen ganz vielleicht auch blödsinnigen Vergleich, aber bei der,
Ja, im Besitznahme des nordamerikanischen Kontinents.
Wir sind an der Ostküste mit ihrem Segelschiff angekommen, aber es wird nie
jemand auf die Idee kommen, eine Mineralwasserkiste von der Ostküste bis zur
Westküste zum Schleppen. So funktioniert Erkundung nicht.
Das kann nicht funktionieren. Darum muss ich eben die Ressourcen,
die ich vor Ort finde, nutzen.
Erst dann wird ein Schuh aus dieser Mission. Und das muss uns gelingen.
Sonst wird die Basis nichts werden.
Ich kann die nicht permanent versorgen.
Deswegen muss ja die Römer auch immer alles plündern, wenn sie irgendwo eingefallen sind.
Ja, das ist natürlich ihr eigenes Thema, Bergbauer auf dem Mond.
Ich glaube, da sind wir tatsächlich noch weit weg, weil du auch so die Umweltgedanken
nochmal angesprochen hast.
Ich glaube, da sind wir noch weit weg, dass das ökonomisch sinnvoll ist.
Und wenn, dann kann es nur darum gehen, Ressourcen vor dem Mond zum Gewinnen,
um diese Basis zum Unterhalten.
Und da ist der Effekt relativ, glaube ich, überschaubar.
Wenn wir jetzt tatsächlich am Südpol landen, dann liegen diese Grate im Schatten.
Das heißt, ich würde diesen Bergbau im Schatten auch nicht unbedingt sehen können von der Erde aus.
Ist natürlich technologisch sehr schwierig, weil ich bei steilen Hangneigungen
bei minus 250 Grad Celsius im Dunkeln irgendwas betreiben muss.
Und jeder, der schon mal versucht hat, ein Auto bei minus 40 Grad anzulassen,
weiß, wie schwierig das ist.
Und da müsste jemand einen Rover haben, der bei solchen Temperaturen autonom
navigieren kann, operieren kann, das Wasser gewinnen kann.
Also da stehen wir noch am Anfang von einer sehr, sehr langen Kette an Fragen
und Technologieentwicklungen, die wir wirklich erstmal leisten müssen, um das zu machen.
Für die erste Zeit könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass so eine Mondbasis natürlich
auch noch von der Erde versorgt werden kann.
Und ich denke, in die Richtung gehen auch erstmal die ersten Überlegungen von
China, die eine Mondbasis bauen wollen und natürlich auch von anderen Leuten,
die eine Mondbasis bauen wollen.
Mit was für Temperaturen müsste man denn da rechnen in diesem dauerhaft beleuchteten
Gebiet? Wie kalt oder warm ist es denn da?
Ja, das dürften so...
120, 120, 140 Grad Celsius sein in der Sonne und im Schatten bin ich so bei minus 180.
In den immer im Schatten liegenden Gebieten bin ich bei minus 250.
Also da geht man ja weder zum Sonnenbaden raus, noch zum Abkühlen ins Dunkle.
Da muss man dann irgendwie eine Methode finden, wie man da wohnen kann.
Gibt es da überhaupt brauchbare Konzepte für?
Also die Alternative, dass man natürlich jetzt nicht zu den Polen geht,
sondern irgendwo vielleicht Lavaröhren auch nutzt.
Wir haben tatsächlich Lavaröhren auf der Mondoberfläche oder auf dem Mond entdeckt
und die seit vielen Milliarden Jahren stabil sind.
Das sind röhrenartige Gebilde.
Also so ein Tunnel nach unten?
Nee, eigentlich so waagerecht. Tatsächlich.
Das sind einfach Röhren, die ein Dach haben und ab und zu bricht das Dach ein
und dann kann ich auch unter den Überhang drunter blicken und weiß eben,
dass diese Röhre nach so einem Zacken weiter geht.
Und das wäre natürlich auch ein mögliches Habitat, klassische Höhle eigentlich,
wie unsere Vorfahren die auch genutzt haben.
Das Problem damit ist eben, dass ich dann 14 Tage im Schatten sitze.
Ich müsste die Sonnenpaneele auch auf der Oberfläche natürlich anbringen.
Und ich habe eben sehr steile, fast senkrechte Wände, die ich erstmal irgendwie
überwinden muss, damit ich in diese Röhre reinkomme. Also das ist schwierig.
Darum denke ich mal, wird es eher vielleicht Richtung Pol gehen.
Aber ganz gleich, wo man landet und wo man seine Basis bauen wird,
Man muss die Astronauten natürlich schützen vor starken Temperaturschwankungen,
vor Sonnenwindpartikeln, also Protonen, die die Oberfläche bombardieren,
vor kosmischer Strahlung, vor Schrauben.
Meteoriten, die auf der Oberfläche einschlagen. Also sprich,
ich brauche irgendeine Struktur,
die die Astronauten dort erstmal schützt und da kann man natürlich jetzt über
aufblasbare Strukturen nachdenken, die man da mit dieser Regolithschicht eben überdeckt.
Oder was auch bei der ESA schon passiert ist, dass man zum Beispiel aus diesem
simulierten Mondstaub in einem 3D-Drucker verwendet.
Ziegelsteine, nenne ich es mal jetzt mal, platt zu drucken. Und bei der ESA
in Estek gibt es einen richtig großen, fetten Block, den man eben über so einen
3D-Drucker bereits gedruckt hat. Und das hat sehr gut funktioniert.
Okay.
Also in die Richtung könnte es gehen. Ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen,
dass das unbedingt dann so gemacht werden muss.
Da muss man halt auch kreativ bleiben und mal schauen, wie man das am besten bewerkstelligt.
Also die müssen so oder so erstmal so explorative Missionen vorausgehen,
wo wahrscheinlich dann auch Menschen vor Ort einfach Dinge ausprobieren müssen.
Insofern sind ja dann die bemannten Missionen, die jetzt wieder angestrebt werden,
eigentlich auch sehr interessant, weil das ja dann eine Notwendigkeit ist überhaupt.
Also ich meine, wenn man da Menschen hinschicken will, muss man erstmal wissen,
wie man da Menschen hinschickt.
Haben wir das zwar schon mal gemacht, aber das Rad muss ja jetzt neu erfunden
werden, beziehungsweise wird gerade neu erfunden.
Mit dieser Artemis 3 Mission soll es ja dann soweit sein.
Ne, hat sich geändert. Artemis 3 geht nur in Erdorbit. Artemis 4 wird die erste Landung.
Artemis 3 wird nächstes Jahr im Erdorbit bleiben, um dort Technologie zum Testen,
Dockingmanövers zu machen und solche Sachen, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Dann Artemis 4. Was geht dir so durch den Kopf und durchs Blut,
wenn du so eine Mission wie Artemis 2 beobachtest?
Da gibt mir natürlich das Herz auf, ist ja klar. Ich meine, wir haben vier Leute,
die da Richtung Mond fliegen, was man seit 50 oder 60 Jahren nicht gemacht hat.
Das ist einfach nochmal was anderes, wenn man mit Menschen so weit weg fliegt,
als wenn man mit einem Roboter entlangt.
Zum Mond fliegt. Also zumindest für mich. Ich kann jetzt nur meine persönliche Sichtweise geben.
Man fiebert natürlich mit, funktioniert das alles.
Ich mache ja auch so Astronautentraining für die ESA, also geologisches Astronautentraining.
Ich kenne viele von den Astronauten und ich weiß, wie gut diese Leute sind,
wie gewissenhaft sich die vorbereiten.
Also man schließt ja dann auch durchaus Freundschaften mit Astronauten und wenn
es dann irgendwann so weit ist, dass ein europäischer Astronaut Richtung Mond unterwegs sein wird,
dann weiß ich jetzt schon, dass ich nicht ruhig schlafen werde,
während der da oben ist. Ja, das ist einfach so.
Selbstverständlich. Andererseits wieder muss ich sagen, ist es einfach nochmal,
viel, viel faszinierender, wenn man sagen kann, man hat diesen Körper mit Menschen erkundet,
als wenn ich sagen kann, okay, wir haben einen Roboter erkundet.
Das soll jetzt nicht heißen, dass ich,
nur mich in der bemannten Raumfahrt sehe und die robotische Raumfahrt am liebsten
gar nicht machen wird. Nee, ganz im Gegenteil.
Ich denke, es ist wichtig, rauszufinden, was will ich.
Ich muss meine Frage, meine wissenschaftliche Frage genau definieren.
Und je nachdem, wie ich diese Frage definiert habe, werde ich mein Werkzeug
aussuchen. Und das Werkzeug kann in einem Fall der Astronaut sein oder es kann
in einem anderen Fall ein Roboter sein.
Diese permanent im Schatten liegenden Gebiete würde ich nie an Astronauten hinschicken
wollen, weil das zu 99 Prozent der Todesurteil ist, möchte ich behaupten.
Da würde ich eher robotische Exploration machen und das ist dann auch gut so.
Andererseits wieder hat halt so ein Astronaut, der gut trainiert ist,
ganz andere Fähigkeiten,
also Intuition, Gesteine zum Erkennen und Interpretationen zu machen,
die dann eben auf die Erde funkt.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Problem mit den ersten Missionen, wo man wesentlich
noch so Flugzeugpiloten rekrutiert hat, weil man dachte, das ist jetzt die wichtige
Fähigkeit, die man braucht, aber man braucht eigentlich Wissenschaftler.
Aber ist auch so ein bisschen falsch verstanden, also keiner der Apollo-Astronauten
ist da hochgeflogen ohne irgendein intensives geologisches Training.
Also das waren völlig richtig Testpiloten, was auch immer,
aber die hatten alle ein sehr gutes geologisches Verständnis,
weil sie eben durch ein sehr rigoroses Trainingsprogramm durchgelaufen sind
und so ähnlich machen wir das ja heutzutage wieder.
Weil es ist,
Ja, wir Geologen verwenden Sprache, die ganz anders ist, als das der Normalmensch verwendet.
Wir schmeißen mit Fachbegriffen durch die Gegend und jeder von uns weiß,
was damit gemeint ist, aber wir können teilweise mit Beschreibungen von einem
Laien nur relativ wenig anfangen.
Und viele Astronauten sind eben keine trainierten Geologen, die müssen erstmal
sich an den Sprachgebrauch gewöhnen, dass wir dann auch auf der Erde irgendwo
im dunklen Hinterzimmer verstehen,
was der da jetzt eigentlich auf der Oberfläche gerade beobachtet und sieht,
damit wir den auch entsprechend unterstützen können.
Und das ist wirklich auch sehr, sehr spannend.
Also ist denn bei Artemis 2 jetzt irgendwas Neues in dem Sinne herausgekommen
oder also selbstverständlich ist es ja die Anwendung der neuen Technik und so weiter,
dass man eben mit den aktuellen Möglichkeiten so eine Mission durchführt,
ist ja an sich ein Learning, aber gab es noch irgendwelche überraschenden Erkenntnisse,
die jetzt dabei gewonnen wurden oder war das im Wesentlichen so ein Abhaken
mit, okay, da hat alles funktioniert, was wir uns vorgenommen haben?
Also das ist natürlich jetzt eine sehr gute Frage.
Und je nachdem, mit wem man redet, wird man auch unterschiedliche Antworten kriegen.
Also natürlich haben die Wissenschaftler, die an dieser Mission beteiligt waren.
Gesagt, man hat was dabei gelernt. Man hat Farbtöne auf dem Mond eben sehen
können oder die Astronauten haben sie sehen können, die Kamera vielleicht nicht
sehen kann. Das mag der Fall sein.
Ich bin jetzt selber an vielen Kameras beteiligt. Ich weiß, glaube schon, was so Kameras können.
Und wenn es um die räumliche Auflösung geht, dann muss ich sagen,
sind natürlich diese Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter Daten um ein Vielfaches besser
als was die Astronauten jetzt selbst mit ihrem Teleobjektiv haben sehen können
vom Mond. Also insofern...
Hat es jetzt für mich keine großen Neuigkeiten gegeben. Man wird aber erstmal
abwarten müssen, was die wirklich genau gesehen haben und was in den Berichten dann auch drinsteht.
Kann ja durchaus sein, dass da noch was um die Ecke kommt, sage ich mal.
Aber ich würde es jetzt eben nicht als Wissenschaftsmission verkaufen wollen,
sondern eher als das, was es wahrscheinlich auch war, nämlich als Technologiemission.
Es ist ja nichts dabei, wenn man mal sagt, man hat hier keine große Wissenschaft
gemacht, sondern wir haben eben unsere Technologie, unsere Methoden getestet
und haben darüber was gelernt.
Das ist ja völlig legitim meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, ich wollte auch gar nicht auf wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse raus,
sondern einfach generell Erkenntnisse aus der Mission.
Es gab ja auch schöne kulturelle Abfallprodukte wie dieses wunderbare Foto von der Sonnenfinsternis.
Das ist eines der spektakulärsten Bilder, das seit langem aufgenommen worden
ist und wo ich sage, das ist jetzt wirklich mal was, wo es noch nie gab,
wo man es so noch nie gesehen hat.
Aber wissenschaftlich glaube ich, kommt jetzt da nicht so viel,
rüber, aber es ist einfach ästhetisch ein wahnsinnig faszinierendes Bild und
es macht eben was mit den Menschen hier auf der Erde.
Die sehen das und sehen, wie toll das eigentlich ist.
Also dass man sowas machen kann, das ist ja schon faszinierend.
Und ich muss natürlich aus europäischer Sicht natürlich sagen,
wir haben ja dieses European Service Module beigesteuert.
Das ist also dieses Teil, das hinter der...
Orion-Kapsel angedockt ist, mit diesen Sonnenpanelen.
Und das ist ein fantastisches Raumschiff, das die komplette Versorgung der Astronauten
übernommen hat, mit Lebensmitteln, mit Wasser, mit Sauerstoff,
mit Raketentreibschiff, mit dem Triebwerk, das uns letztendlich zum Mond gebracht hat.
Und das hat sehr, sehr gut funktioniert.
Und das ist eine Leistung, die wir hier in Europa natürlich,
wo wir auch stolz sein können,
dass wir sowas haben bauen können und dass eben die NASA in dem Sinn von dem
fehlerfreien Funktionieren von diesem ESM auch abhängig war,
weil ohne diesem Service-Modul wären diese vier Astronauten auch nicht zum Mond geflogen.
Die Chinesen planen ja auch eine Mondlandung, glaube ich, so 2030.
Genau, mhm.
Die machen das aber immer noch alleine, oder?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Das ist mittlerweile auch ein größeres Konsortium von
Nationen und Ländern, die sich da beteiligen wollen.
NASA und ESA sind da komplett außen vor, weil die Chinesen natürlich Partner
haben, mit denen wir momentan auch nicht zusammenarbeiten, inklusive Russland.
Und damit ist die Zusammenarbeit für diese Mondbasis da eher schwierig, zumindest momentan.
Also die planen auch eine Mondbasis, nicht nur eine Landung.
Genau, langfristig soll das auch eine Basis werden.
Und ja, wie gesagt, da ist Russland dabei, Südafrika meines Wissens,
ich glaube auch der Iran, Venezuela, Pakistan, dann, also das ist auch so eine
ganz wilde Mischung nennen wir es mal.
Ja, also,
Ja, das wird haben wir das nächste Space Race sozusagen vor der Tür Das.
Kann man so sehen, ja, dass das eine Space Race ist, ja,
Chinesen waren wie gesagt 2030 dort dann im Landen mit bemannt,
ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es durchaus früher ist die haben,
2029, ein größeres Staatsjubiläum. Und ich könnte mir gut vorstellen,
dass man eben dieses Staatsjubiläum dazu verwendet, um zu demonstrieren, wie gut man ist.
Und ich habe es ja vorher erwähnt, dieses chinesische Programm ist sehr strukturiert,
baut einen Schritt auf den anderen auf.
Und diese ganzen Missionen, die in den letzten Jahren so geflogen worden sind,
waren eigentlich fast immer alle pünktlich.
Also die sind zu dem Zeitpunkt geflogen, wo man auch fliegen hätte sollen.
Gut, mal vielleicht ein halbes Jahr oder was, hin oder her.
Aber im Regelfall ist es ja sehr pünktlich.
Ich habe heute Morgen erst die Nachricht bekommen, dass im NASA eine Studie
betrieben hat, dass der Raumanzug vermutlich nicht rechtzeitig fertig wird für die 2028-Landung.
Also wie sicher ist dann dieses Datum 2028 und zwischen 2028 und 2029 ist da
nicht mehr viel Unterschied.
Insofern ist es ein Space Race ja, also.
Wird auf jeden Fall.
So gelesen werden das Ergebnis dann noch offen ist, möchte ich sagen,
ja.
Worauf freust du dich denn jetzt am meisten dass es jetzt da vorangeht abgesehen
davon, dass alles toll ist, was mit dem Mond zu tun hat.
Also ich bin natürlich wenn man so schön auf Neudeutsch sagt wenn man sich 30
Jahre mit dem Mond befasst.
Und ich habe tatsächlich zwei oder drei Jahre damit verbracht,
einen Teleskopdatensatz vom Mond zu kalibrieren, bevor dann die ersten Galileo-Daten
und dann die Clementine-Daten kommen sind.
Also ich komme aus einer Situation, wo man sehr, sehr wenig Daten gehabt hat,
den Mond global zu untersuchen und jetzt an einer Mission beteiligt,
die enorme Datenmengen liefert und wo es absehbar ist, dass man eben bemannt
wieder zum Mond zurückkehrt.
Also für mich sind das natürlich super spannende Zeiten.
Also für mich geht gerade so ein Traum in Erfüllung, muss ich wirklich sagen.
Und worauf ich mich am meisten freue,
Jetzt denke ich, dass auch die ESA in diesem Mondkonzert hoffentlich eine wichtige
Rolle spielt und wir hoffentlich auch einen europäischen Astronauten auf die
Mondoberfläche bringen.
ESA fliegt enorm viele erstklassige Missionen.
Also wir müssen uns nicht verstecken, aber in der bemannten Raumfahrt sind wir
leider eben noch von unseren Partnern abhängig.
Und ja, darum wäre es jetzt höchste Zeit, dass wir eben auch ein Europäer Richtung
Mond auf den Weg schicken können.
Also im Prinzip auch die eigenen Fähigkeiten dafür aufbauen,
eigene Technologie auf Basis von Ariane 6 und den anderen Entwicklungen, die dort noch kommen.
Ist das so im Gespräch? Also hast du den Eindruck, dass es dahin geht?
Ich denke ja. Ich meine, wir erleben ja jetzt diese Diskussion generell über
viele Themenbereiche hinweg, sei es Verteidigung, sei es Wirtschaftspolitik,
also dass Europa unabhängiger werden muss und resilienter werden muss gegenüber
äußeren Einflüssen, politischen Unsicherheiten,
glaube ich, ist auf der Agenda ganz weit oben mittlerweile.
Und das Gleiche gilt natürlich auch für die Raumfahrt. Also das ist nur die
logische Entwicklung, die wir durchlaufen müssen.
Bei der letzten Ministerkonferenz sind ja die Mittel auch stark angestiegen für die ESA.
Also alle Missionen können umgesetzt werden, teilweise besser finanziert wurden
als selbst beantragt wurde.
Man merkt schon, dass sich das anders drauf konzentriert. Jetzt will ich auch
nicht sagen, die Sicherheit Europas muss auch auf dem Mond verteidigt werden,
aber letzten Endes gehört es ja irgendwie auch alles zusammen.
Also man merkt einfach, wie wichtig das für die Amerikaner war,
dass sie viele Starts hatten und viele Starts waren ja auch nur möglich,
weil man eben sich auch darauf konzentriert hat, viele Forschungsmissionen zu
unterstützen, die dann zu vielen Starts geführt haben, was dann wiederum dazu geführt hat,
dass sie jetzt diese Vormachtstellung bei den Launchern haben,
während Europa da noch kräftig hinterherhängt.
Man hat zwar gute Technologie, aber man hat sich halt nie so darauf konzentrieren
können, weil halt einfach die Gesamtmasse an eigenen Missionen dann doch überschaubar war.
Und ich glaube, auch mit dem militärischen, sicherheitspolitischen Bedarf,
der jetzt neu definiert wird,
ändert sich das langsam und man lässt es halt nicht unbedingt jetzt auch gleich
noch woanders entwickeln, sondern es könnte schon dazu führen,
dass letzten Endes die gesamte Forschungslandschaft davon profitiert.
Ja, so funktioniert ja auch die Zusammenarbeit mit der NASA.
Was man natürlich vermeiden will, ist, dass man europäische Steuergelder im
Koffer nach Amerika schafft und dort den Flug für so einen Astronauten sich kauft.
Da ist ja niemanden gedient dabei.
Das entwickelt keine Industrie mit.
Genau. Was wir natürlich, wo unser Interesse natürlich ist, ist,
dass wir dieses Geld haben, das immer über die Mitgliedstaaten an die ESA fliegt,
dass wir das natürlich auch in Europa ausgeben.
Und darum gehen solche Verhandlungen immer dahin, zum Beispiel eben Verträge
zum Schließen, dass wir in Europa dieses European Service Modul bauen müssen.
Dort europäische Steuergeld in europäische Firmen stecken, in europäische Arbeitskräfte
stecken, Arbeitsplätze sichern im Hochtechnologie-Bereich.
Und dieses Produkt, das fertige Produkt, wo ich auch meine eigenen Technologien,
meine eigenen Fähigkeiten entwickelt habe,
dass ich dieses fertige Produkt dann der NASA zur Verfügung stelle und im Gegenzug
dafür eben dann ein europäischer Astronaut dann hoffentlich mit zum Mond fliegen darf.
Also das ist so der Sinn der Sache. Und.
Ich hoffe, dass das eben gelingen wird. Es ist jetzt auf der letzten Ministerratskonferenz nochmal,
gerade von deutscher Seite, sehr viel Geld in die Hand genommen worden und da
kann man der Bundesregierung einfach auch mal nur mal applaudieren.
Man kann auch mal sagen, die machen auch mal was richtig, weil Raumfahrt,
glaube ich, ist schon eine zukunftsorientierte Sparte.
Da wird Hochtechnologie entwickelt, da werden Fähigkeiten entwickelt,
die ich auch anders einsetzen kann.
Und das ist schlichtweg eine Investition in die Zukunft.
Und wenn man als Land konkurrenzfähig bleiben will und attraktiv bleiben will,
dann muss ich glaube ich schon in diesem Sektor zeigen, was ich kann.
Und da sind wir glaube ich ganz gut aufgestellt.
Und es sieht so aus, als ob die Zukunft demnächst vor allem auf dem Mond stattfinden
wird, abgesehen natürlich von den anderen Missionen, die weiterhin gemacht werden.
Aber das ist jetzt sozusagen der neue Fokus und in dem Theater werden wir demnächst
einige interessante Aufführungen sehen.
Es bleibt spannend auf alle Fälle.
Ja Harald, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen.
Sehr gern, es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Mondforschung. Und ja, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Es geht schwer was ab. Mal gucken, wer als erstes den nächsten Fuß auf die Mondoberfläche
setzen wird und mit welchem Brimborium das dann gefeiert werden wird.
Aber es fällt auch eine ganze Menge ab für die Grundlagenforschung,
weil Universum verstehen ist ja auch noch wichtig, auch wenn sich das immer
nicht so gut macht in der öffentlichen Werbung.
Aber diese tiefen Erkenntnisse, die nutzen einem immer dann im Moment,
wenn man gar nicht damit rechnet.
Ja, nochmal vielen Dank und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Das war es heute von Raumzeit. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.